من جانبه قال الرئيس التركي والمرشح
الرئاسي عن تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
انه لا يمكن ان يكون لدى المعارضه هدف
كالحفاظ على وحده البلاد وشعبها وفي كلمه
الله خلال مهرجان انتخابي باسطنبول اتهم
اردوغان المعارضه بالعمل مع من وصفهم
بالارهابيين ومع من يهدف لضرب اقتصاد
تركيا
رسائل من تعاون مع الارهابيين لنقل حلقه
النار والدماء التي دمرت سوريا الى تركيا
واليست واضحه رسائل من دعم مخططات مستغلي
الاقتصاد ومساعيهم في افلاس تركيا
وليست واضحه رسائل من انزعج من الغاز الذي
اكتشفناه في البحر الاسود ومن النفط الذي
اكتشفناه في جبل جبار واسالكم انتم هل
يمكن ان يكون لهؤلاء هدف كالحفاظ على وحده
بلدنا وشعبنا وقوه بلدنا وبقائه